-Guys, today is Friday, and
that's usually when I catch up
with some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was running a bit behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
I'd like to write out a few
thank-you notes right now
if you wouldn't mind.
James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing music,
please?
♪♪
Ooh, there he is.
Big "House of the Dragon" fan.
-Wow.
-Loves --
-Loves High Valyrian.
-Loves it.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, fall wreaths, for
being the international symbol
for "someone's got a glue gun."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Oh."
-"Oh, I burned my hand."
-Thank you, Buccaneers vs. the
Chiefs, or as it's also known,
the G.O.A.T. versus the goatee.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
-It's a good one?
That's a good one
you just thought of?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm just thinking all these
off the top of my head.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I probably have three or four
more thoughts.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-But this is definitely --
-Yeah. This -- Yeah.
-Thank you,
New York City public schools,
for offering more
plant-based meals.
Soon the bullies will be like,
"Hey, nerd, take
'my' lunch money."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Hey-o!
-That's a good one.
Yeah, that's great.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't want it.
Yeah, just take it."
♪♪
-Oh, wow, your pen broke.
[ Laughter ]
Got to get a new pen.
-I got a different one.
-That one's out of ink.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you, challah,
for being bread with abs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Thank you, hotel cereal
dispensers,
for being bird feeders
for businessmen.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Imitating bird whistling ]
[ Screeches ]
[ Pop ]
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, corn maze,
for being the most fun way
to get trapped in a vegetable.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are the thank-you notes.
We'll be right back
with Zac Efron!